Rebecca John she's the one who accused
DeSantis of hiding covet numbers yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey these are red flag
laws why why is this lady complaining
her kid got red flag
this is exactly what Democrats have been
asking for why wasn't she concerned
about her son's death threats because
she's she's evil these people are evil
bro it was a rhetorical question no but
there's an answer because we talk about
this so often when I point out here is a
woman who knows full well what her son
did she is capitalizing off of the fact
that her son is reported to have
threatened to murder classmates and
she's using it for political power she
tweeted before I'm getting out of
Florida or something like this and then
she never did now why would she say such
a thing and then not follow through oh
because they're Liars because she's
lying then when her son gets arrested
because the family is clearly unwell she
says they kidnapped my son and she's got
followers who are eating it up and she
is using this stuff for political gain